il y a quelque chose d'Alice au pays des
merveilles dans l'air au château de
Breteuil
samedi dernier la troisième édition du
Tour de France photo posé ses valises
pour la première fois à choisir
et prise de vue en américain
pour essayer de voir si on arrive à
avoir le contraste du nuage avec le
soleil
une journée de shooting photo où chacun
est bénévole et profite gratuitement
d'un décor féérique de quoi laisser
s'exprimer l'imagination des artistes on
essaye de donner un petit peu de
l'esprit un petit peu marrant aux photos
quoi comprenez par terre mais je suis
souvent couché par terre moi je suis un
peu barré
trois photographes 15 modèles si
préparateurs les artistes ont été
sélectionnés sur dossier sur les 750
réponses nationales seules 500 ont été
retenus ils enchaînent les scénettes au
rythme des envies depuis le début de la
journée ça change ouais c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus original c'est ça ça
change beaucoup de ce que je fais moi je
fais vraiment que de la mode
pratiquement ou de la beauté commerciale
en fait du coup c'est vrai que
l'ambiance change énormément et c'est
vrai que ça me plaît beaucoup
ces photos serviront aussi à faire
évoluer son book car tous les
participants disposent ensuite des
clichés ici on joue la Marie-Antoinette
des temps modernes avec une canette de
soda par exemple pour cet artiste qui
travaille en auto-entreprise c'est
l'occasion d'agrémenter son réseau
j'ai rencontré des gens intéressants
des photographes qui auraient pu être
des concurrents et au final ils vont
devenir des traits de très bons potes
le Tour de France photo c'est aussi 4000
km parcourus par Thomas son fils et un
associé le tout dans un camping-car
c'est une bonne ambiance on va dire une
ambiance de mec on bouge d'une ville à
l'autre on se débrouille un peu comme on
peut c'est vrai que ce serait peut-être
pas donné à tout le monde mais même si
il y a déjà 20 personnes qui nous ont
demandé pour participer l'année
prochaine je sais pas si on va grandir
si on va prévoir un deuxième camping-car
ou prendre un minibus ou un gros je sais
pas
un livre souvenir 60 mètres d'exposition
au sol le Tour de France photo c'est
achevé le week-end dernier en Alsace
après 15 jours de road trip artistique
aux quatre coins de la France